and you may not know it but some of the
people that are giving you the most
trouble
may be helping you more than anybody you
have no idea
how frighteningly average and normal i
am
if you have a habit of just talking
about your problems all the time
it's time to make a new habit bunch of
people old before their times because
they
they look like you know they're 40 and
look like they're 90 because they've
worried themselves to death
she's a charismatic christian speaker
author and
pastor she speaks humorously with her
audience sharing her personal stories
and often taking small jabs at
stereotypical church behavior time
magazine also named her one of the 25
most influential evangelicals in america
she's joyce meyer and here's my take on
her top 10 rules for success
rule number four is my personal favorite
and i'd love to know which one you guys
like the best also as joyce is talking
if she says something that really
resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well
and also when you write it down it helps
lock it in for yourself
enjoy
i tell a story about a poor pitiful
donkey cause i got thrown down in a well
he
fell into a well and
the farmer heard this donkey crying in
the well and
he was trying to debate on whether or
not i tried to get him out or not the
well was deep
and it was going to be a lot of hard
work the donkey was old anyway and so
maybe we'll just bury him and
let it go so he went and got a bunch of
friends and said let's just
bury him help me shovel some dirt in
there and so he'll shut up that
crying he's an old donkey and not worth
too much anyway and you know there may
be a lot of people that think you're
just an old donkey and not worth too
much anyway
maybe feel like you're in a pit right
now and somebody's shoveling dirt on you
well what are you going to do about it
well the donkey's down there and he's
crying
out pitifully
[Applause]
[Applause]
and here come a shovel full of dirt and
then another shell of the foot and a
shovel full of dirt and it would hit him
on the back
and he'd go
[Applause]
get on top of it here comes some more
dirt some more dirt and some more dirt
he'd shake it off his back he'd wiggle
just a little
he couldn't get out of the pit but he
could wiggle and he'd get up on top of
that dirt
and he was getting closer and closer to
the top and pretty soon he just walked
right out of that pit
all those people shoveling dirt on him
helped him get out of the pit
are you out there tonight all those
people shoveling dirt on him actually
helped him and you may not know it
but some of the people that are giving
you the most trouble may be
helping you more than anybody are you
living an unsustainable life
do you find yourself saying i can't do
this much longer
i just can't keep this such forever keep
this up forever
this is just too much for me are are
other people telling you
you can't keep going on like this
forever
come on how many of you got some people
in your life that love you telling you
you can't keep this up you can't keep
doing this you're going to have to slow
down you're going to have to
lay something down you're going to have
to give something up well
moses had the same thing he was
overloaded but to be honest i don't know
that he really knew it
and you know i'm such a hard worker that
sometimes i can just i cannot even
realize
that i'm doing too much sometimes i
don't even know when i'm being excessive
and somebody has to come along and say
wait a minute
you're not going to do that you just got
back from a conference you're going to
rest
so sometimes it pays to listen to other
people exodus 18
14.
[Music]
when moses's father-in-law saw what he
was doing for the people
he said what is this that you do for the
people why do you sit alone
and the people stand around you from
morning till evening
now listen mom why do you
wait on your children hand and foot
while they sit around and watch you and
do nothing but play on their ipads from
morning till evening
[Applause]
well
let me tell you something that kid of
yours could put cereal in a bowl
they may make a little mess but it won't
be the end of the world
if you're enjoying yourself sitting in
your recliner and you're relaxing
let them get their own snack
oh boy come on i don't want to work this
hard on friday night
why do you sit alone while everybody
stands around you
now you don't all have that problem but
i have a daughter that does that
you can just get into habits and the way
you start with people
is what they're going to expect later on
so then if you've already got a bunch of
bad habits in your house
then it's going to really kind of shock
everybody when you
kind of bring down the gauntlet and say
i'm not going to live like this anymore
and they're going to think you're being
mean and think you're being bad and so
there'll be a little time of adjustment
and it doesn't mean you don't do
anything for anybody but don't let
people take advantage of you have some
boundaries and some borders
some of you need a laugh right now so
i'm going to stop right in the middle of
this preaching and tell you a joke
[Applause]
well i honey i've never been in a church
like this well
two old people were laying in bed side
by side i'm talking really old
like wrinkled up old
and she said honey why don't you ever
hold my hand like he used to at night
so his little old wrinkled hand came
across the bed and
he took her little wrinkled hand
she said honey why don't you ever hold
me in your arms like you used to at
night
so he sighed and it took him a little
while but he got over to her side of the
bed
got her in his arms and she rested a
little bit and then she said honey
why don't you ever nibble on my ear like
you used to at night
[Applause]
and all of a sudden he jumped up and
started across the floor and she said
well where are you going he said well i
got to get my teeth
[Applause]
now see you're thinking well what does
that have to do
with anything nothing it has nothing to
do with anything
and that's exactly what you need to get
through your head
that everything doesn't have to have
some big super duper
purpose
[Applause]
it's okay to just stop right in the
middle of some work and just have a
little bit of fun
matter of fact you could laugh at
yourself and lighten up your life a
whole lot
and look at me let me tell you something
you can believe
what you want to believe
you're going to believe something it
might as well be something that's going
to help you
it's just as simple actually it's easier
to believe you can
than to believe you can't it's easier to
believe you
are than to believe you aren't now you
know based on what you guys tell me you
you love me you like me you know you
tell me
you know i think you're this i think
you're that blah blah you've changed my
life
you have no idea how frighteningly
average and normal i am
i mean it's like sometimes i'm walking
around and somebody will run up to me
say ah you're joey
and i'm like oh yeah oh yeah i'm joyce
meyer
[Applause]
but see actually the truth is is i'm
just like you
and you're just like me we're all just a
big mess
with jesus living on the inside saying
you got what it takes
if there is any difference in me and you
and there doesn't have to be but if
there is any
it's only because i've decided to
believe it and you haven't quite decided
that yet
you can get over a broken past if you
decide to believe
that there's nothing in your past that
can keep you from having a great future
first peter 5 8 says be well balanced
are you living a balanced life
how many of you don't get enough sleep
no matter where i go it's the same thing
80 of the people don't get enough sleep
well
what's going to fix it start sleeping
[Applause]
that's simple get more sleep
well i i can't sleep i have trouble
sleeping well
don't spend all day worrying then maybe
you'll be able to go to sleep at night
how many of you don't drink enough water
[Applause]
well we can fix that too drink water
you know this is this is not rocket
science
i mean i'm trying to tell you tonight
that you can fix your life
faster than you think you can fix your
life fear is something that's not ever
going to completely disappear from our
lives the feeling of fear
is not ever going to completely
disappear and just because you feel fear
that doesn't mean that
you have to be afraid and i don't know
about you but that was a real great
revelation to me many years ago because
i kept
wanting to not feel afraid and god
wanted me to feel the fear
and be courageous anyway courage means
to go ahead and
take the action that you believe you
should take or that you know god wants
you to take
while you feel fear we let our feelings
dictate to us way
too much and so the only acceptable
attitude that a christian can have is
simply i
will not fear so let's all say that
i will not fear
now once again that doesn't mean that
you'll never feel fear matter of fact i
can pretty much promise you
that you will but it does mean that you
can feel the fear
do whatever you believe that you're
supposed to do
while you feel afraid you can learn to
do it afraid
if that's the only way that you can do
it don't let the feelings of fear keep
you trapped any longer
now first of all let me say this a
positive attitude
attracts people a negative attitude
usually doesn't win you very many
friends
now i don't want to hurt anybody's
feelings but i just want to throw this
out for you to think about
everybody does not want
to just hear your problems all the time
[Applause]
now it's great to have a good friend
that you can share with
but you don't have to share and share
and share and share and share and share
and share and share
and share and share and then when you
wear that one out go find another one
and share and share and share and share
and share and share
so if you have a habit of just talking
about your problems all the time
it's time to make a new habit
and that is to find something good to
talk about and
i'll just throw this out for good
measure too your friends don't want to
just hear you talk about yourself all
the time
and i remember god telling me in the
very very beginning of our ministry
if you can not complain about where you
go to do meetings the day will come when
you'll be able to go anywhere you want
to
and hold a meeting well that's pretty
much true
today but i had to go through a lot of
rough places and difficult places
and i think a lot of people i want you
to listen to me a lot of people never
get to where they want to be because
they'll never stop
complaining about where they're at i
must say it again
a lot of people will never get to where
they want to be
because they will never stop complaining
about where
they're at the word complain means to
remain
or to stay overnight so if you want to
stay right where you're at
just keep complaining about it and i can
pretty much guarantee you
that you'll still be there this time
next year i mean can we believe tonight
that jesus didn't die
so we could be wimpy and whiny
and barely get when i'm just so i'm
underneath i'm just so tired of this
i just don't know if i can make it or
not jesus
come on
[Applause]
a bunch of people all before their times
because they
they look like you know they're 40 and
look like they're 90 because they've
worried themselves to death
[Applause]
i mean come on you stay full of the holy
ghost and you're going to look younger
when you're 80 than you did when you
were 40.
[Applause]
let's look at acts verse 1 chapter 1
verse 8.
[Applause]
look at this but you shall receive power
[Applause]
i knew that god had power but i went to
church for years and nobody told me i
could have any power
[Applause]
so just in case nobody's ever told you
[Applause]
i want to tell you in this room and all
of you watching by television
all around the world in these 63
languages this program is
translated into whether you're in china
or russia or
india or africa you can have
power
god wants you to have power to live
your everyday life where even when we
are loaded down with troubles
we can throw our shoulders back and lift
our head up and say i can do whatever i
need to do through christ
who strengthens me
i am not without an answer i am not
without a way
because god is living in me in close
fellowship and he will show me what to
do
if we don't understand the power of god
no wonder
being a christian is so boring there's
nothing you can do
let me just tell you that i was so
selfish
oh my gosh i was so selfish
i was always on my mind
now you know if dave was going to go
play golf the first thing i'd think is
well what about me
and if they was going to watch a
football game what about me
they're the kids that go outside with
dave to play and i had work to do inside
now you know mind you i could have not
worked and went out and enjoyed myself
but no
i i wanted to work so i could feel sorry
for myself
come on and everything was well
what about me you know what about me
when's somebody gonna do something for
me
and i started early in the morning
before i was even fully awake thinking
about myself
any of you like that and so
many many many years ago i was laying in
bed one morning and i wasn't even fully
awake yet and i was thinking about how i
could get dave to
not do what he wanted to do that day and
do what i wanted and
you know how i could maybe get the kids
to do the housework so i could just kind
of chill and
you know have fun and
it was like i was just thinking about
myself just
laying there in bed thinking about
myself and you know that's a dangerous
way to start your day because however
you get started that's usually the way
things go the rest of the day
and you're much better off to lay in bed
and purposely think god what can i do
for somebody else today
how can i be a greater blessing to my
family how can i god how can i be a
better wife today
the last time i asked god that he told
me to cook dave's breakfast i haven't
asked that in a while
because i'm not into too much cooking
and
poor guy about fainted when i said i'm
going to cook your breakfast so
you got to be ready when you ask god
that kind of stuff
and uh but it's been life-changing for
me the principles that i'm sharing with
you tonight really has been one of the
key
elements in my life that have gotten me
from where i was to where i am so i'm
laying there thinking about myself
i kind of had like this little vision
and the holy ghost began to deal with me
in my heart and he said you know
the enemy comes and starts putting
thoughts in your head
real early in the morning and it's like
he's getting you wound up for the day
he said you you remind me of this little
robot
the devil comes and he's like what about
me
what about me what about me
and what about me
and then you put your feet on the floor
and this is the way you look to me the
rest of the day
what about me what about me what about
me what about me
beep beep what about me what about me
what about me
thank you guys so much for watching i
made this video because natasha o'mara
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next
leave it in the comments below and i'll
see what i can do i'd also love to know
what did joyce say that had the biggest
impact on you which rule did you love
the most and why
leave it in the comments i'm gonna join
in the discussion finally i want to give
a quick shout
out to megapure thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and making that awesome youtube
video on your channel
i really really really appreciate the
support and hope you're enjoying the
book
so thank you guys again for watching i
believe in you i hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever
your one word is much love i'll see you
soon
you know we all have really the same
amount of time
each of us get 24 hours every day
we don't get any more we don't get any
less well why is it that some people can
do
so much with their time and other people
don't seem to ever
accomplish what they set out to
accomplish with their time
all right we hear this comment all the
time or we hear ourselves saying it i
know
i say it where did all the time go
i can't believe this day is gone i can't
believe it's already spring
i can't believe it's christmas and we
hear that all the time well
where does all the time go to be honest
i think we should know
where our time goes and one of the
things that i've farmed the habit of
doing i don't do it every single day but
this really helps me is people who live
busy lives fast-paced lives
sometimes a whole day can go by in a
blur and you know you were busy but
you're not really sure what you did you
did it all so fast that you can't even
hardly remember what you did
and one of the things that i enjoy doing
is just laying in bed for a few minutes
at night before i drift off to sleep
and actually starting with my morning in
my thoughts
and thinking about everything that i did
that day i got up
made my coffee went up to my office
had some time with god looked over my
calendar you know whatever it was that i
did
i like to go through those things
because then it helps me actually
remember
what i'm doing with my life i don't want
my life to go by in a blur and i don't
think you do either
i believe that every day that god gives
us is a gift
and i think we should open that gift
fully
and completely enjoy every single
moment of it some people don't enjoy
their lives because they feel like they
have too much to do all the time
well then make some changes don't let
what everybody else wants
run your life take your life back
i think under god's direction and
leadership we need to take charge of our
lives
and we need to start putting our time
into what we want to put it into
instead of just what everybody else
wants us to put it into
and i don't mean by that that we don't
do things for people we all should be
busy doing things for other people we
all should serve
we have jobs we have responsibilities
but don't just let all your
circumstances rule you
and everybody else's decisions about
what they want you to do for them
rule you take your life back
so i want to share with you a little
exercise that i think that you can do at
any time
i've been doing this and i'm finding it
very refreshing and
that is simply to stop several times a
day and just say
lord i want to just live this moment
that i'm
in you know so often we don't
we're breathing but we're not really
living the moment that we're in
we're in such a frustrated uproar over
all the things that are going on in our
lives that
so much of our day just flies by and at
night we don't even really know what we
did but we know it was pretty
frustrating and
we didn't enjoy all that much of the day
and i think it's a very good exercise
to stop several times a day and just say
now lord i'm going to enter into this
moment
and really just live this moment and
to think about and to tell god what
you're thankful for at that particular
moment
in your life and there was a certain man
verse 5
who had suffered with a deep seated and
a lingering disorder for 38 years
a deep seated and a lingering disorder
for 38
years it's this man right here
and jesus said a most amazing thing to
this man
when jesus noticed him lying there
helpless
knowing that he'd already been a long
time in that condition
he said to him do you want to become
well
what kind of a question is that
do you want to get well sure
and then jesus goes a little deeper he
says are you really
in earnest about getting well
and then the most amazing thing the
invalid answered him
and said
i don't have anybody to put me in the
pool
and every time i try somebody gets in
front of me and
they get their healing and not me
so when jesus said to him do you really
want to get well he said
i have nobody to put me into the pool
he was waiting for somebody to do it for
him you say well joyce
give the guy a break he was crippled
well i want to tell you something in 38
years
i could have done a lot of wiggling
[Applause]
i mean in 38 years if you only wiggled a
little
part of an inch every year i mean he had
365 days to wiggle
just a little bit but the only thing he
could say to jesus was
there's nobody to put me in the pool
and when i try to get on somebody gets
ahead of me now jesus
didn't say oh you poor man i cannot
believe
that you have been laying here 38 years
and nobody has put you into the pool
that is really terrible
i know it's really bad isn't it
[Music]
yeah just really bad
i'm glad you're starting to see things
my way
yeah you're he's getting this he's
actually got i think tears in his eyes
now you know jesus being loving and kind
i would think that he would have just
said that is the most horrible thing i
have ever heard i am going to fix your
problem tonight
but here is what jesus said to him
verse 8 jesus said to him get up
get up get up and
pick up your bed and walk go home with
that mess you've made in the last 38
years
get out of here and live your life get
up